[Musique]
oh
et
l'ancien notaire je veux acheter la
petite ville avec some cuisine salle de
bains les binômes kepiro mais placard
aux balais et qui me coûte que 350 avec
les frais cela ferait ce un signe ici
[Musique]
pourquoi riez vous met donc le contrat
est signé je peux bien pour dire la
maison et anti tiques de hanter parquet
la sorcière du placard aux balais et et
l'essentiel ne vient que la belle reste
bien sage dans son seulement attention
si vous avez le malheur de chanter sous
un beau ciel sorcière gros gars de ton
du lierre et espèce d'idiot
vous aviez bien besoin de me chanter
dans le reee pareil maintenant je vais
plus penser qu'à ça
[Rires]
mais que faire attention
oubliez cette chanson après tout c'est
le jour et je suis pas dans ma maison
sens hier sens il prend garde à temps
derrière tu dans ma maison mais elle
joue et je peux chanter sens hier 106,1
prend garde à temps derrière les mois
passèrent et une nuits s'il chantait
juste un petit bout de la chanson du
moment où je la chante pas en entier la
sorcière plus rien contre moi sorcières
essentielle
[Musique]
sorcières censier reprend
ce ancien ressentir prend garde
[Musique]
s'enquiert essentielle prend garde un
sens hier essentielle prend garde à ton
censier 106 enfants garde-t-on d'air
sens hier son ca prends garde à temps
derrière tout ça y est j'ai dit oui et
pourquoi dois je prendre garde maman
derrière moi je demande pardon madame tu
chanter ça sans y penser sans y passer
il te manquer bien de moi lorsque tu
seras en tête à petite chanson jusqu'à
l'avant dernière syllabe
mais ces pays c'est mon tour de m'amuser
pitié madame j'aime beaucoup les
sorcières ne me fait pas de mal mais je
te propose une épreuve
tu as trois jours pour me demander
pourquoi chose possible
et si je ne peux te donner sinon je vais
réfléchir à demain madame la sorcière
bonjour bachir une méchante sorcière de
m'emporter tout ce qui pourrait le
sauver c'est lui demandé trois choses
impossibles si elle ne peut me donner
satisfaction
même une fois je serai sauver petit
monde à ta petite souris y interprète
qu'elle demande à des poissons magique
s'ils n'ont pas une idée oui petite
souris petite amie parle avec mes petits
poissons et tu auras du saulcy sans
écoute ce soir quand tu verras la
sorcière demande lui des bijoux
très
sorcières donne moi des bijoux en
caoutchouc qui brillent comme des vrais
[Musique]
pour commencer sa pas marché beaucoup
demandent à la sorcière une branche de
l'arbre
[Musique]
je veux une branche de l'arbre macaronis
qui puisse pousser dans mon jardin
[Musique]
ça n'a pas marché je suis perdu adieu
bachir n'a rien n'est perdu
c'est honteux de se décourager comme sa
petite souris interroge encore les
poissons beaucoup public écoute c'est
toi demande à la sorcière qu'elle te
donne la grenouille acheter elle sera
bien embarrassée parce que la chronique
à cheveux c'est elle voici ce que tu te
ra
[Musique]
donne moi la grenouille à cheveux je
veux la grenouille à cheveux tu peux pas
me la donnez alors vas tu en voilà la
grenouille bachir sans ses cheveux toute
sa force était dans ses cheveux fait
depuis maintenant qu'une grenouille
ordinaire 4 quel des petites souris
elle ne veut pas très digne
[Musique]